you know when you stop and look at it
one film in pixar's catalog
truly shows us the dangers of the
rampant consumerism in today's culture
it's a statement on the human desire to
accumulate more
and more and more useless stuff that
just becomes garbage
meaningless trash that eventually cycles
back to becoming meaningless trash
and that movie is
thunder hollow challenge quick fix and
they're back on the beach on separate
other cars these souls are related each
cell
sold separately each sold batteries not
included sold separately separately
[Music]
cars
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that does the dirty work of
sifting through mountains of detail with
the efficiency of a wall-e robot which
is to say
not very efficiently at all but hey at
least we try really hard you know if
there's one thing to say about my
favorite pixar movie wall-e
it's that it's not exactly subtle with
its theme the earth has been transformed
into a post-apocalyptic wasteland
left in a ruined state by humanity's
wasteful consumerism and not in a cool
way like sakhar and thor ragnarok
plastic sporks rubik's cubes leftover
twinkies the kinds of trash that you and
i produce on a daily basis litter every
square inch of the planet
the message is beaten over our head we
didn't take care of our earth and
now you've inherited our problems we
didn't listen every soup tin that you
toss every banana peel that you give the
slip and every diet coke can that gets
canned is part of the problem
you you dear viewers sitting in the
theater eating your jumbo tub of popcorn
and your mega-sized coke have made this
earth uninhabitable with your wanton
lust for more
more stuff more things and now humanity
has been forced to take to the stars
while these innocent little robots been
forced to clean up our mess for the last
700 years
b l starliners leaving each day we'll
clean up the mess while you're away
this movie wants to give us a wake-up
call to get us to go
green and keep blue to crush us with
guilt every time we get an amazon order
and see all those little air pouches
that come
packaged with it that you just gotta pop
before you can
throw them all away because they take up
so much damn room in the garbage
and while i hope all the theorists out
there are for environmental
responsibility there's one thing that
i've learned from years of watching
movies and tv shows and that's
you can't believe everything you're told
at face value
and wally here for as much as i love it
is no exception
when you actually stop and question the
events of the movie you start to realize
that
something sinister is afoot a planet
covered in garbage is just one part of a
larger conspiracy in the pixar universe
and today
i'm gonna prove to you that everything
we've been led to believe about wally
and its trash filled cities is complete
and total garbage in the opening scenes
of wally we see abandoned buildings
light poles street signs and other
indicators that this was once a thriving
metropolis
this indicates the breakdown of one of
the most basic things required for a
modern city
to function a waste management system
that transports waste
out of the city towards landfills i
don't know if you've ever stopped to
think about it but nearly all of a
city's trash
is transported out of the city to
landfills that can be hundreds or even
thousands of miles away from city limits
and though that might seem like a dirty
business
both literally and figuratively waste
disposal is
big money contractors get into bidding
wars over the ability to take away
a city's trash and then i start eating
garbage
i'm the trashman because not only does
it allow you to collect on a city's tax
dollars you know
all that stuff that's taken out of your
paycheck for sanitation expenses but
landfill waste actually tends to produce
methane gas which many landfills are
designed to capture
and turn back into electricity just two
landfill gas energy facilities can
generate enough electricity to power
16 000 homes so basically trash
collectors are double dipping payment to
take out the garbage and then
extra payment for selling electricity
made from that garbage back to the city
it's a fantastic business
if in wall-e humanity can afford to
create rockets that transport everyone
off the planet then it can
absolutely very easily afford to have
trucks deliver trash to landfills
as long as there is space literally
anywhere in the world we're not gonna
have the problem that's depicted in
wall-e
which means that for the situation to
have gotten this bad the world must have
run out of space for landfills
except that one isn't going to be true
either you see trash is a problem that
people in science and business have been
studying for a long time
one of those people was the
self-proclaimed garbologist dr
william rathgee an archaeologist
professor at university of arizona who
turned his powers of archaeology not
toward studying dinosaur bones or
millennia old human remains but studying
the way that humans manage and treat
trash hey not all archaeologists are
gonna be indiana jones okay
that belongs in a museum according to an
article by dr
rathji and smithsonian magazine the
total amount of land mass needed to
contain all of our trash
isn't that large a single landfill 120
feet deep and 44 miles square would be
able to handle the us's waste for the
next
hundred years now granted that's a
landfill the size of delaware which
sounds like a lot but remember that's
our second smallest state it's one
twentieth of one percent of the us's
total land mass
point zero zero zero five and that's to
handle
all of the waste created by the entire
us for a hundred
years if we kept filling landfills at
the same rate we do now
after ten thousand years we would still
have only covered
five percent of our total available area
10 000 years later in short the prospect
of running out of space for all our
trash anytime near the future just isn't
realistic
and certainly not realistic in the
700-year future of wall-e
not even in the 10 000 year hypothetical
future besides by the time humanity gets
that far we'll probably have other ways
of dealing with trash more efficient
ways or
you know just launching it into space
and sending it out into the sun
but i know what you're thinking all of
that is at our current rate right what
about the future we're gonna get more
and more wasteful and generate more and
more garbage as the years go on right
that's what i was thinking too but when
you actually sit down and do the
research
this assumption turns out to be
incorrect for as weird as it might seem
as time goes on and our society becomes
more
advanced the amount of waste we produce
goes downward
every year we're figuring out ways to
make our packaging more and more
efficient
in the 1950s we replaced heavy and dense
glass bottles with plastic bottles then
we replaced
those plastic bottles with thinner
bottles you see it all the time on items
like water bottles this bottle is
designed to use 20 percent less plastic
and this waste reduction is all thanks
to companies being run
under the idea that green is good but uh
not
environmental green no it's not nearly
that altruistic of a goal
money money green is good when a company
figures out how to make a bottle with 20
less plastic sure it's good for the
environment but it's also good for the
bottom line
it means they saved money by
manufacturing 20
less plastic packaging foam gets slimmer
every year why
not because companies care about the
environment but because the less
packaging material you use the less it
costs and the more items that you can
fit into a shipping container or a
warehouse this is one of the places
where businesses driven by profit
actually make the world more sustainable
even when they're not intentionally
trying to be environmentally friendly
being green
simply nets you more green our intuition
would say that more development equals
more consumption equals more waste but
in the world
right now less advanced societies tend
to produce
more waste because they don't benefit
from all the innovations that we have in
producing more efficient packaging
food preservation techniques like
refrigeration and a transportation
network that ensures that food is always
getting to the people who are able to
use it rather than being unsold and left
to rot
the average person living in new york
city right now generates
less waste than a person living in
mexico city
in short as the world gets more and more
technologically developed we're gonna
produce
less and less waste not more even things
like saving paper
we do things all digitally now so we've
saved tons and tons of paper
all of this the obvious profit motives
that companies have to deal with our
city's trash problem the indirect
profit motive of companies wanting to
use less materials and make things more
efficient and the relatively small
amount of land mass it would take to
create a landfill to deal with it all
makes it seem like the futuristic
dystopia that we see in wall-e
should be impossible there is no way a
city could fill up with garbage like
this
this quickly unless this was
intentionally what you were trying to do
but that would be stupid right who would
intentionally want to fill up a planet
with garbage b
l starliners leaving each day we'll
clean up the mess
while you're away too much garbage in
your face there's plenty of space out in
space because at b
l space is the final fun time
too much garbage in your face
[Music]
so get ready for the adventure of a
lifetime the axiom is waiting
and the stars are calling
that's right the company responsible for
the wall-e program that's supposed to
clean up the earth's trash problem was
the one that intentionally created the
earth's trash problem to begin with
why well it's simple by getting the
earth's population onto by and large
starliners like the axiom by and large
has what marketers refer to as a captive
audience
people who have no choice but to consume
your products and your advertisements on
board the starliner the company has an
absolute monopoly over humanity with no
opportunity for competition everything
about these people's lives from the
entertainment they're viewing to the
food they consume
is all managed by this one single mega
corporation
children are even indoctrinated from
early childhood to consume by and large
products b is for by and large everyone
seems to think that humanity's rampant
consumerism inadvertently turned the
earth into the uninhabitable wasteland
that it is that the b
l starliners were the solution the
company came up with to solve it but
look at the way the b
l starliners are advertised they show
people living in luxury
almost like space is a getaway vacation
spend your five-year cruise in style
waited on 24 hours a day by our fully
automated crew
this doesn't look like a disaster relief
program at all it looks like a space
cruise that was designed as a way to
siphon people's cash away
but there's just one problem with that
not everyone is willing to go to space
a survey by the manpower research agency
found that only 32 percent of workers
would be willing to permanently relocate
overseas even if it meant getting a
better job in advancing their career
if only 32 of people are willing to
cross the border for a better life how
many fewer people would be willing to
leave the entire planet and everyone
they know and love for the unknowns of
outer space
no it's not enough to entice people off
the planet when no one was willing to go
on their expensive space cruises they
needed to find a way to
force people off of the planet and what
better way than to turn every city into
a huge contamination zone and not only
do they have the motive
they have the means to do it they're the
largest seller of goods in the pixar
first so they could very easily create
less efficient products
then they would throttle the sanitation
supply i mean you see it in up
by and large controls construction
companies so chances are they could also
control the waste disposal companies too
because what's better than saving a
couple bucks by being green
well stealing everyone's lifetime income
by keeping them captive on your space
cruiser
in wali we see the world reduced to a
desolate wasteland and all this time
we've been led to believe that this was
something that happened because of us
because humanity was careless and
wasteful and didn't look after the
environment but the truth is far more
sinister
it was by and large corporate greed that
caused this to happen
this without a doubt solidifies by and
large as the most sinister pixar villain
of all time i mean sure syndrome killed
a few people but by and large
killed an entire planet now go out and
recycle a can
our fate hangs in the balance but hey
that's
just a theory a film theory
and cut
so those are the awful things that by
and large did on planet earth if you
want to see the even more horrific
things they did once they got humanity
up in space click the box to the left
the wally cannibalism theory or if you
want to see my take on the pixar
connected universe theory that box is to
the right and make sure you subscribe
you made it this deep into the video
chances are you liked it if you want
more pixar theories well get ready
because more are in the works but you
won't see them
unless you subscribe chances are you
might not see them even if you subscribe
but hey
help your chances out